well let's get right to it it's time for
some over/under on the various watches
that will be going on in the 2019 season
if you're confused you won't be stick
with us we're gonna start with the first
one it's the Jason Garrett hot seat
watch the over-under that we have set is
week eight when does the hot seat watch
begin for Jason Garrett specifically is
he I guess the way we're supposed to do
this is is he gone does the hot seat
begin week eight or is he gone week
eight let's do it with he's gone by week
eight no over/under are you over are you
let's go hot seat then yes I'm still
over I'm gonna go over and you know
again I feel a lot more comfortable of
Ezekiel Elliott was there but I still
look at this football team and just go
man there is just talent everywhere it's
hard to really find a weakness in the
roster of the Dallas Cowboy football
team and the other thing I think that
leads me to say over to is hey coaches
know it's a big year they're desperate
you know they know the seats mi warm to
begin with and here's the other point if
you're watching on TV the schedule
especially early on pretty favorable you
know Giants Redskins Dolphins hey I
expect the Dallas Cowboys on the team
they have to beat those three teams
Saints I know Packers hey those are
dicey at the Jets they should win those
so I just can't imagine them being in a
bad enough spot to wear the hot seat
walk no I'm gonna I think that this
means when he's out Chris because week
eight is their bye week and that is the
traditional time where the opportunity
is to say see you hit the road right and
I you know I I think that I don't think
that he'll be gone by then I don't say
look Jerry Jones has only fired one head
coach during the season and that was
Wade Phillips and that was after
insisting he's not gonna fire Wade
Phillips and I did but you know what if
the first half of the season is it just
flat-out total disaster and they're out
of contention as a practical matter and
I know anybody can turn it around in the
second half but sometimes bringing in
that interim head coach is what helps
you turn it around in the second half so
I are you know under either standard I
think week eight is a fair assessment
because that's the opportunity to fire a
Jerry to fire a Jason Garrett if you're
Jerry Jones that gives you the maximum
time to get a new guy ready and I don't
think that's all that unreasonable
because he's entering the
year of his contract and if the Cowboys
have a disastrous start if they're two
and six that's a fair point to look at
and although I don't think they're gonna
have that kind of a disastrous start so
I think he'll keep the job all year long
but you know it's it's at least worth
discussing because he's in the last year
of his contract you're not talking about
that big buyout that would happen on the
back end right but you're going
overwrite that that's official you said
the over if you haven't going over yeah
I think I'm going over okay all right
just wanted to clarify all right let's
move on to the next one then and we'll
do these as when the uproar begins among
media and fans just to make it clear the
bench
Eli uproar week six over or under oh
gosh this is a tough one I was
encouraged to the way you know it's only
through one pass I was encouraged the
way Eli looked and I of course I've told
you that I have so many great reports
about Eli through training camp so far
in the way he looks and the arm looks
better the mechanics have gotten a
little tighter as far as how he throws
the football I think I'm going to go
over here too and this is this is I
don't feel totally comfortable with this
but I think with the way they're gonna
play the offensive line being fixed up
say Quan Barclay I think this is a team
that's trying to prove something
everybody because hey we can still win
if Odell Beckham jr. is not here it's a
big year for Pat Shermer his second year
number your number one wasn't all that
great to where I think maybe he can hand
it at least shut off the boo birds maybe
til about week nine or ten le I don't
know if like three and three I don't
think that's gonna be enough to get it
done two and four I don't think that's
gonna bring out the total boo birds
either I don't think the Giants fans
here are expecting Super Bowls so I
think they'll give a little leeway to
Eli look at week six though what is
that's at the Patriot right and if they
go to New England and if they get lamb
basted by the Patriots that that is when
it's gonna start because the arguments
going to be hey you've got the Cardinals
coming to town exactly right that's a
game that Daniel Jones can win start
them at home against a team that is
trying to find its way and new head
coach and the defense may not be very
good and Daniel Jones could have a
confidence builder so if the team
doesn't decide that Daniel Jones should
be
starter before week six I think that is
the moment that's dead on the moment
when the fans are gonna start clamoring
so I'm not gonna go over or under I'm
gonna say week six is right there so
make it week six and a half and I'll
take you're going to push you're just
going to push there I'm going to push
yeah cuz I think that's that the way
it's set up that's when the fifty lie is
still the quarterback that is most
likely the point where the fans are
going to say we want Daniel Jones if not
earlier
I'm tempting I'm still gonna go push I
attempted to say under well I know it
would help if we could see Eli Manning
in more than three players you know
that's the toughest thing about some of
these you know you want to see a little
more evidence to just go what does he
look like what is that off that's gonna
look like in totality but nonetheless
this is what we're doing and it's fun so
let's keep it going
all right the Dwayne Haskins watch week
six to be the starting quarterback in
Washington we don't know who the weak
onestart is gonna be Adrian Peterson
thinks Colt McCoy has the edge Case
Keenum is there as well
week six for the rookie 15th overall
pick who looked a little rough last week
in Cleveland in his preseason debut
Chris what do you think yeah I want to
tend to go with the under on this one
because of there is no Eli Manning this
a plant you know the people I really
respect Case Keenum I think he's a lot
better than people give him credit for
but the public I don't think necessarily
agrees with that assessment nor is he a
household name or a guy that fans and an
organization want to latch on to to go
oh this is a franchise guy look at him
so I don't I'm not seeing good things
for the Washington Redskins I mean
there's aspects of their team I like the
Trent Williams situation is scary to me
I don't know what to think of them
overall right now who were the weapons
in the past game all those things
concern me with Washington and I think
because of Dewayne Haskins and his
talent and the fact that there is not
that marquee guy ahead of them that we
see some of the people clamoring in
Washington to just to get him out there
and let's get the Dewayne Haskins era
started something I hadn't noticed what
we were watching Dwayne Haskins
highlights earlier yeah it's preseason
for the yellow line guy - did you see
the hey finish the field and it was
crooked yellow line guys in the
preseason all
so but if we could pull that frame up
that would be hilarious but anyway
Dewayne Haskins I think you're right
this is like half there his uh yellow
line guy you need a little work it's
good but there's four preseason games
yellow line guy oh yes you know yards
there you have one job yellow line guy
all right so with Dwayne Haskins it's
like having a brand new car that
everybody wants to drive and meanwhile
you're tooling around in the Ford Escort
no offense and the the Chevy Vega I mean
what we know what Colt McCoy can do we
know what Case Keenum can do we don't
know what Dwayne Haskins can do let's
put the pedal to the metal let's take it
out on the road and let's drive it and I
think there's gonna be that type of
anxiety among Washington fans especially
because let's face it do we really
expect them to be good they started off
really good last year because they had
Alex Smith this year at the Eagles
that's a loss Cowboys that's a loss
bears that's a loss at the Giants maybe
you get lucky probably not Patriots
that's a loss so yeah they're gonna be
wanting to see what Dwayne Haskins can
do because they're gonna be feeling by
the middle of October like it's over
anyway and the same thing you said with
like the Daniel Jones thing you know
it's at the Patriots and then the next
week is the Dolphins where you'd go oh
okay yeah let's start them against that
team I mean it that makes sense as far
as that logic goes - all right a be
tantrum watch second quarter of week one
oh come on that's not fair I'll take the
under
I will definitely go with the over I
think we don't see a tantrum you know
for a few weeks into the season
I mean week one I really envisioned this
like he's gonna have ten receptions by
halftime he really is now it might be
ten receptions for like 64 yards or
something like that but they're gonna
feed the beast I know that and yeah you
know you watched Hard Knocks last night
and last week hey this is the new toy I
mean Gruden's ready to pull his hair out
that he hasn't been able to you know
have fun with this guy out on the
football field he will make up for it
and make sure Antonio Browns happy
because it's gonna make him happy - when
the offense is getting him the ball so
I'm certainly going over there hey I
will say this he's not gonna have ten
catches he's gonna have ten targets
whether they actually are caught depends
upon how act
the passes are thrown to him that is the
great laboratory experiment here that
it's been glossed over by the frozen
feet by the helmet fight will Derek Carr
be able to deliver the ball as
accurately as Ben Roethlisberger could
Antonio Brown and what will Antonio
Brown do the first time a hospital ball
gets thrown in his direction he has to
stretch out he takes a big hit from it
so I I'm not taking the under cuz it's
kind of funny that it's set for the
second quarter of week 1 but I won't be
surprised if at some point on that
opening Monday night because the cameras
are gonna be on him it's gonna be like
the old days with Randy Moss everywhere
where Antonio Brown goes right they're
gonna be watching him so even the
slightest little thing is gonna get
magnified and I think there's a chance
something is gonna happen in that first
game cuz I don't think it is gonna start
as smoothly as most people presume that
it will all right one more before we
take our break the Gronk watch week 5
over I'm going over there all the way I
mean just the way he looks right now
he's gonna mean need more than just week
five to get back to where he needs to be
physically to play tight end I'm gonna
push that one to where I don't think
Gronk wants to deal with football in
October if that happens I think it's
gonna be Halloween time you know early
October he's really gonna feel the itch
and I could see if anything it's be that
week 10 bye where maybe some phone calls
get made to go hey coach I'm getting the
itch and I'm back in the waiting room
and I'm almost back to my wait I think I
want to get back in I would go that like
that week 11 Eagles game I can imagine
that in a crazy world and then you know
the question becomes when do we really
start talking about the Gronk watch but
you look at the early season schedule
and I know the Patriots always start
slowly because the early regular season
is basically an extension of the
preseason for them and it takes them a
while to get their sea legs but they
should be able to handle who knows I
mean if they it could be by week five if
they would lose at home opening night to
the Steelers like they lost a home
opening night to the Chiefs a couple of
years ago and then you go to Miami they
always have a hard time in Miami and
Brian Flores you're gonna have something
ready for a metro huh I it could it
could be that the fans are clamoring to
go get drunk by the time week five rolls
around I'm gonna take the under he may
not come back until week ten but I think
the fishies there he is
if you're watching on TV with that dog
boy but he doesn't
to put on about 20 pounds Chris but I
know from the week that I spent at the
beach it's and all that hard to gain
about ten pounds in a week if you really
put your mind to
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports